I want to follow up on yesterday's two
segments on Green Party candidate Jill
Stein we did a segment yesterday two
segments really and to sum them up I
won't redo it today
one segment argued that Jill Stein's
campaign and ideas are riddled with
pseudoscience positions on a number of
issues we also talked about Jill Stein's
running mate of mr. Baraka essentially
being an extremist with very very odd
ideas some people were very very angry
about those segments and some people
emailed me really really thanking us I
want to show you some emails and YouTube
comments and voicemails that we received
in response to this first here is an
email i received from lee roy who said i
don't know how much money you received
for your betrayal but i hope it was
worth it many of my friends are
cancelling their membership yeah nobody
cancelled their membership that this guy
knows and we often are threatened with
that louis and the funny thing about
that and I've said this before and I'll
say it again
we don't have memberships to allow
people to hold them over our heads when
we say something they don't like
imagine if the membership program was
structured so that when someone says
you'd better change your position on
this or I will cancel my membership we
would actually be doing something that I
think would be very very unethical and
immoral yeah we wouldn't be able to have
a position on anything well no yeah
practically speaking it would prefer
ebuddy is gonna disagree with something
but no we don't change or take positions
based on threats that you will stop
money coming from us that's actually how
corporate media works with advertisers
and we're trying to separate ourselves
from that Curt wrote to me Curt said
it's like Jill Stein is a trump of the
left seemingly picking up any
harebrained left-wing causes to appease
the most liberal voters in temperament
she is like Trump as well the way she's
attacked her opponents and the way her
overall campaign is run Trump handles
himself in this kind of absolutist way
and it works with conservative voters
but I think Jill Stein is proof that
these kind of politics don't work with
liberals well I think it works with some
there are people for whom that type of
rhetoric is resonating I received a
another email from Rowan Rowan said the
David Pakman show now just another
corporate-controlled Hilary supporting
mainstream media source if you believe
that you know very very little about
this program and lastly I received an
email from Argo
who said thanks for calling out Jill
Stein I know that some segments of your
audience cares first and foremost about
ensuring that Hillary loses in November
clearly based on the YouTube comments
you guys annoyed them by pointing out
that Jill Stein has it best pandered to
anti-science idiots and at worst is one
herself keep doing what you're doing we
didn't use that term to be clear this is
just a sampling of the reaction and
lastly here is a voicemail from someone
who is really not happy with us over
those segments I don't hope David Pakman
gets this message I did I personally am
embarrassed by the critique of Jill
Stein David the all you did was display
your intense mediocrity your
intelligence could not even match
one-fourth of Jill's times the only
thing that you're motivated by is your
arrogance and your meager knowledge of
human emotions of politics the quality
of your show is like high school
you must be producing it yourself
Boyet has no bearing on reality you're
like a little boy you have a lot to
learn yeah it's embarrassing listen to
you right so a a critique completely
without substance full of ad hominem
attacks yeah and well who else would be
producing this show of course we
produced the show I mean it's just like
a weird thing no actually Roger Ailes is
producing the show
yeah we're producing the show I don't
know what kind of a critique you know
someone else who wrote an email thought
George Soros might be producing the show
yes of course one correction I do want
to make yesterday I said that the Green
Party supports funding for homeopathy in
their platform they did for a long time
but recently change that and no longer
officially support funding the non
science debunked non treatment of any
sim
or condition based on actual scientific
evidence that we call homeopathy I do
want to correct that yeah that's a great
thank you for that and can I add one
thing please I looking at the YouTube
comments I love how if we do a critique
or even or bash if you will Jill Stein
then we're corporatists were funded by
the Hillary campaign but if we do that's
a Trump it's all just fine
it's so fallacious to say that anywhere
that we coincide with any entity that
you consider to be corporate or
mainstream by definition we are paid by
and part of that system and of course
this is easily debunk able if corporate
media were to report that France has
been attacked by Islamic terrorists and
we report that France has suffered
attacks by Islamic terrorists are we in
some way in cahoots with the corporate
media towing party I mean it's just a
ridiculous argument and we really need
to be analyzing substance and specifics
and just this is a sampling of what we
received hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of comments and emails and
tweets on the matter will continue
calling it like we see it send me your
thoughts on Twitter I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman Warby Parker is offering a free
five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDP s I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing